este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
square space ya sea en páginas web
tiendas online o herramientas de
marketing y analíticas square space es
la plataforma todo-en-uno para construir
una excelente presencia online y operar
tu negocio
[Aplausos]
año 1955 corea del sur es un país
corrupto inestable y muy dependiente de
la ayuda exterior devastado por la
guerra corea del sur se sitúa en ese
momento como el tercer país más pobre de
asia
[Música]
su renta per cápita era equivalente a la
de países africanos como ghana soportaba
la mayor inflación de todo el continente
y la menor tasa de crecimiento
gobernado a partir de 1961 con mano de
hierro por el autoritario general hyung
y las expectativas para este país no
eran nada pero que nada buenas corea del
sur era un país de inmigrantes e incluso
su vecino del norte parecía más
prometedor pero un momento amigos porque
esta no es la historia que todos
conocemos
[Música]
corea del sur es hoy el país del capo el
que beauty el key fashion y los dramas
y también del quinché esa cosa roja que
parece que los coreanos comen a todas
horas y que a mí personalmente me
encanta
[Música]
en definitiva hablamos de un país que
está de moda amigos la ola coreana
también conocida como el high y llega
prácticamente a todos los rincones del
planeta ahora bien no penséis que se
trata sólo de una cuestión cultural en
absoluto las empresas surcoreanas como
samsung hyundai o lg también extienden
sus tentáculos por los cinco continentes
[Música]
[Aplausos]
triste
y no es para menos este país corea del
sur ha sido protagonista de una de las
mayores historias de éxito económico de
todos los tiempos en poco más de tres
décadas en apenas una generación corea
del sur- pasó de ser un país del tercer
mundo a convertirse en uno de los países
más ricos y prósperos de la tierra
[Música]
y la pregunta es cómo consiguió corea
del sur todo este desarrollo como logro
convertirse en un país tan rico pues no
está hoy no es la pregunta porque esto
ya os lo contamos en un pasado vídeo que
os dejo por cierto en la descripción el
caso es que gracias al particular modelo
de desarrollo surcoreano caracterizado
por grandes grupos industriales los
chavales por un sistema educativo muy
exigente una enorme apertura al mundo
una gran acumulación de capital y
políticas activas de absorción
tecnológica se produjo el conocido como
milagro económico surcoreano
pero amigos lo que nos ha traído hasta
este vídeo es que hoy todo este modelo
parece agotado en 2017 ganó las
elecciones este hombre el actual
presidente muniáin con una promesa a
apostar por nuevas políticas que dieran
un vuelco al modelo económico de corea
del sur y ojo porque no estamos hablando
de políticas nada pero que nada
convencionales atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un modelo agotado
si corea del sur es hoy uno de los
países más ricos del planeta y sigue
creciendo pero su modelo tiene problemas
y muchos indicadores presentan una
tendencia negativa fijaos por ejemplo se
espera que en 2019 el país registre el
menor crecimiento de los últimos siete
ejercicios su tasa de desempleo tuvo en
enero su peor registro en nueve años los
salarios no crecen y los jóvenes cada
vez tienen más problemas para encontrar
un empleo algo nada frecuente en la
corea del sur de los últimos 30 años
desafortunadamente ya que nosotros
mismos no vemos el futuro de korea con
bastante optimismo no quiero traer niños
a esta sociedad poco prometedora creo
que esta forma de pensar es compartida
entre muchos de mis colegas bueno
supongo que os parecen motivos
suficientes como para preocuparse verdad
pues esperad porque aún hay más
los hogares las familias de corea del
sur acumulan deudas equivalentes a casi
el 100% del producto interior bruto lo
que les convierte en los hogares más
apalancados de todos los países del
mundo
y es que veréis si los surcoreanos
ahorran mucho pero también invierten
mucho especialmente en viviendas y luego
encima por otro lado la mayoría de los
empleos son tan poco productivos que las
jornadas laborales se extienden una
barbaridad y cuando digo barbaridad me
refiero a una barbaridad con todas sus
letras fijaos
[Música]
aquí
corea del sur termina con la inhumana
larga jornada de 68 horas semanales
el presidente introduce una semana de
trabajo de 52 horas para ayudar a
mejorar la calidad de vida a impulsar la
natalidad sino trabajo horas extras mi
salario se reduce preferiría trabajar
más para poder cobrar más
vamos que tal y como veis la sensación
de agotamiento del modelo es muy intensa
y ojo porque estamos hablando tan solo
de la punta del iceberg veréis la
economía surcoreana tiene algunas
características muy a tener en cuenta
[Música]
por un lado la economía de corea del sur
está dividida por así decirlo en dos
grandes partes los enormes chavales que
tienen una importancia gigantesca tan
solo los diez mayores grupos del país
representan más del 40 por ciento del
producto interior bruto estos grupos
reciben favores y privilegios del
gobierno controlan entidades financieras
y tienen comportamientos que persiguen
limitar la competencia dentro del país
y luego por otro lado están las pymes
las pequeñas y medianas empresas más de
35 millones de empresas que no tienen
privilegios que están sujetas al enorme
poder de los chavales algo que tiene
importantísimas consecuencias
por ejemplo los salarios promedios de
las pymes que es donde trabajan la
mayoría de los surcoreanos son
aproximadamente la mitad la mitad que
los salarios en las grandes empresas y
la brecha no para de crecer
[Música]
porque pues entre otras cosas porque los
grandes chavos se comportan de forma
monopolística y hay muchas sospechas de
colusión entre estos grupos muchos
políticos
[Música]
es decir que los directivos de un grupo
se ponen de acuerdo con los directivos
de otro grupo y también con los
políticos para limitar la competencia y
repartirse el mercado entre ellos ante
esta situación su poder sobre las pymes
es enorme si no acepta sus condiciones
simplemente tienes que cerrar y no se
trata de que exista solo una diferencia
salarial durante los últimos años el
número de pymes que se declaran en
bancarrota no deja de crecer
y
por si todo esto fuera poco el
desarrollo tecnológico de países como
china está incrementando la competencia
y la presión sobre la economía
surcoreana que es muy pero que muy
dependiente de las exportaciones
exageradamente dependiente de las
exportaciones
pues bien esto está haciendo que los
chavales trasladen parte de su
producción a otros países y que
sustituyan a proveedores locales por
proveedores extranjeros las compañías
coreanas no pueden competir con china e
india- en precio y deberían ascender en
la cadena de valor pero la evolución
industrial hacia productos de alto valor
añadido no está teniendo lugar en el
sector de las pequeñas y medianas
empresas por su dependencia con los
conglomerados es algo que está pasando
sin ir más lejos que con la industria
del automóvil
[Música]
corea del sur es uno de los mayores
fabricantes de automóviles del mundo
pues bien a pesar del bombo momento que
se ha vivido en el sector durante los
últimos años la producción surcoreana
lleva tres años consecutivos cayendo por
qué pues porque hyundai que controla el
70 por ciento del mercado nacional está
trasladando producción y proveedores a
países como méjico e india
al final amigos los privilegios que el
gobierno ha dado a estos grupos y las
acciones que éstos han tomado para
limitar la competencia han hecho que la
mayor parte de los empleos estén ligados
a compañías poco productivas con poca
eficiencia y poca inversión en
investigación e innovación
y claro si no tienes esas cosas pues no
puedes competir con países como china o
vietnam que tienen costes laborales
mucho más pequeños y esto es algo que
está generando mucho miedo en corea del
sur pero precisamente muniáin el
presidente ganó las elecciones de 2017
prometiendo resolver todos estos
problemas y sabéis que tiene un plan
poco convencional como quiere muniaín
rescatar a corea del sur bien veámoslo
[Música]
el plan del presidente mundial
queridos amigos de visual politico
muniáin ha prometido cambiar el modelo
económico de corea del sur de arriba a
abajo y no penséis que quiere hacerlo
con las recetas típicas de menos
impuestos o menos regulación todo lo
contrario el plan del presidente
surcoreano se sustenta en dos pilares el
primero de ellos consiste en lo que sus
partidarios denominan democratizar la
economía
[Música]
en la práctica consiste en elevar los
impuestos e incrementar el gasto público
el empleo público y el salario mínimo
vamos el cóctel completo y no
precisamente en pequeñas cantidades
mirad
en 2019 el gasto público crecerá más de
un 10% y el mayor incremento en una
década por su parte el salario mínimo
creció un 16 4% en 2018 y en 2019 subirá
un 10,9 por ciento adicional y el
gobierno ya ha dicho que ahí no se van a
terminar las subidas ni muchísimo menos
asimismo para financiar más gasto
público y la contratación de 850 mil
nuevos empleados públicos
muniaín ha impulsado la subida del
impuesto sobre los beneficios de las
empresas que va a pasar del 22 al 25 por
ciento y también se va a subir el
impuesto sobre los salarios más altos
la idea que tiene el gobierno es que
todas estas medidas lb en los ingresos
de las familias y con ello su consumo lo
que reduciría la dependencia que las
empresas surcoreanas tienen de las
exportaciones el problema pues amigos
que no está funcionando veréis desde que
muniáin ha empezado a tomar estas
medidas la economía se está
desacelerando el desempleo ha comenzado
a crecer y para colmo los ingresos de
las familias con menos ingresos no sólo
no están subiendo sino que están cayendo
[Música]
y habéis escuchado bien sus salarios
suben pero muchos trabajadores han
perdido su empleo de tal forma que el
resultado neto es que el 20 por ciento
de las familias con menos recursos
ingresan menos dinero hoy que antes de
la subida de los salarios mínimos
todo esto explica que el índice de
aprobación del presidente haya pasado
del 84 por ciento a mediados del 2017 al
45 por ciento a día de hoy pero amigos
antes de terminar nos queda ver el otro
gran pilar en la estrategia del
presidente surcoreano atentos
[Música]
mirando al norte
amigos del presidente surcoreano está
convencido de que el futuro de su país
pasa por corea del norte estamos en la
línea de salida histórica hacia una
prosperidad común en la península de
corea y en el noreste asiático esta es
una oportunidad que ha surgido como un
milagro es una oportunidad que nunca
deberíamos perder
[Música]
veis este mapa en el podéis ver los
planes que muniáin tiene para corea del
norte quiere impulsar tres grandes
cinturones económicos que conecten el
corazón industrial de corea del sur con
corea del norte con china y con rusia
mediante nuevas líneas de ferrocarril
carreteras gasoductos redes eléctricas
etcétera etcétera tan solo las
inversiones que se estiman son
necesarias para impulsar los nuevos
trenes supondrían más de 40 mil millones
de dólares
corea prevé que la red de ferrocarril
transiberiano llegará de nuevo a busán
la punta sur de la península coreana
donde crecí construyéndose sobre la paz
permanente la península
[Música]
y amigos con todos estos proyectos el
presidente quiere mejorar las
capacidades comerciales de la economía
surcoreana al tiempo que le da a sus
empresas acceso a los recursos y a la
mano de obra de corea del norte veréis
se calcula que el salario mensual de un
trabajador norcoreano podría estar en
torno a los 60 dólares que es mucho
menos que lo que cobran los trabajadores
chinos o vietnamitas para samsung
electronics corea del norte es un buen
candidato en el que establecer líneas de
producción porque puede ofrecer mano de
obra barata no tiene barrera lingüística
y tiene la misma zona horaria el
problema pues que aquí muniáin tampoco
está teniendo excesiva suerte
por un lado las negociaciones entre
corea del norte y eeuu van despacio muy
despacio por otro lado las empresas
surcoreanas no ven muy claro que puedan
invertir miles de millones de dólares en
corea del norte a corto plazo entre
otras cosas porque no se fían del
régimen de kim jong un
y luego está la última pregunta quién va
a pagar todo ese enorme gasto que se va
a necesitar para llevar a cabo los
planes del presidente en fin esta es la
receta con la que muniaín quiere
transformar el modelo económico
surcoreano más impuestos más gasto
público más empleos públicos sale los
mínimos más altos y corea del norte
pensáis que funcionará espero que este
vídeo os haya resultado interesante pero
antes de terminar dejadme que os hable
un poco sobre square space si tienes un
mensaje importante que trasladar puedes
hacerlo con square space quizás tengas
la necesidad de tener una web donde la
gente pueda encontrarte o quizás acabas
de crear tu propio negocio y necesitas
empezar a desarrollar tu presencia
online o tu propia tienda bien pues todo
esto es posible gracias a square space
en square space encontrarás plantillas
para tu web con diseños chulísimos o si
a lo mejor no te interesan las
plantillas y tienes el talento y la
creatividad para diseñar tú mismo tu web
también puedes hacerlo por tu cuenta sin
plantillas
square space hace súper fácil el poder
construir un espacio que resulte
increíble en square space puedes
registrar un dominio nuevo o también
mover uno que ya tengas el proceso es
súper sencillo
pero si te surge cualquier duda square
space ofrece un servicio de atención al
cliente 24 horas donde encontrarás
siempre a alguien que te pueda ayudar lo
dicho si queréis tener vuestro propio
espacio vuestra tienda online lo que sea
hacerlo realidad con square space be
square space.com para una prueba
gratuita y cuando tengas todo listo veas
cuerpo puntocom barra visual polític s p
para ahorrarte un 10% al adquirir tu
primer website o dominio y como siempre
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]